j'aimerais démarré par vous elisabeth
donc elisabeth racontez nous votre
histoire vous êtes la mère d'une victime
je sais que c'est difficile mais non
j'étais à la maison je regardais même
pas la télé vision est en fait c'est un
coup de fil c'est le petit copain de ma
fille qui m'a dit j'ai perdu clos et il
ya des attentes a donc gelé mais la télé
et tout de suite on a dit il faut
absolument commente à paris
voilà donc on est monté à paris sans
trop savoir ce qui s'était passé quoi
parce que voilà on a perdu chloé avec
gala de votre fille 25 ans 25 ans et
elle habitait aux invalides mais en fait
elle travaillait dans le 11e
donc le carillon c'était un petit peu
leur base voilà et ce soir là il faisait
beau sur les terrasses donc voilà est
allé alors vous avez des questions pour
elisabeth pour en poser question
également eric bon on peut évidemment
que ce que s'incliner devant ce qu'ils
est arrivé moi j'aimerais vous poser une
question quand on a perdu sa fille dans
ces circonstances et c'est une question
d'ailleurs que je pourrai adressé aussi
à grégory mais on parlera de son livre
tout alors peut-être sait comment est ce
qu'on peut continuer à vivre parce que
vous savez souvent alors c'est un peu
une lapalissade mais souvent dit il ya
une sorte de logique dans la vie des
parents partent d'abord et puis il y les
enfants suite quand quand votre fille
disparaît comment est ce qu'on fait pour
continuer à cheminer à vivre alors tout
d'abord on prend pas de conscience dans
les premiers mois dans les premières
semaines ni dans les premiers instants
qu'elle est partie en fait c'est ça fait
trois ans mais c'est maintenant le plus
dur en fait puisque ça fait trois ans
que je n'ai pas vu ça fait trois ans que
je vais pas serrer dans mes bras et
c'est maintenant que je prends
conscience de ce qui s'est passé de sur
le moment il est lé premier temps on
continue à vivre manger
il me reste cinq enfants et cinq
petits-enfants donc en fait je suis
obligé de continuer à vivre et c'est ce
qui me tient c'est ce qui me c'est vrai
que j'ai eu envie
quelquefois d'aller la rejoindre mais il
ya trop de choses qui me retiennent
encore ici quoi elisabeth est ce que
vous avez encore des moments de joie
oui mais toujours entachée d'un petit
peu de culpabilité voire pas dire que je
vais rire et je vais me dire comment tu
peux rire quoi ça c'est en fait je sais
que c'est tout à fait normal de rire
mais j'avoue que chaque moment de joie
ou de je me surprends à chanter dans la
voiture et je me dis bah non
vous avez déclaré quelque chose vous
avez dit que vous avez envie de refuser
de payer vos impôts
oui ça c'était sur le coup quand j'ai su
que ça d'abdeslam était en prison moi je
me suis dit je paierai pas pour que ce
type là reste en prison donc je ferai
pas mes impôts mais on sait très bien
qu'en france si on paye pas ses impôts
sur c'était une réaction voilà c'était
une réaction vraiment donc dans le coup
j'ai avec mon avocat nous avons goûté un
dossier pour qu'une loi arrive à passer
et que cette loi ce soit que quand le
terroriste a été déclaré coupable bien
sûr ce soit lui qui rembourse son procès
et oui son procès alors voilà il ya
plein de témoins autour de nous pouvait
poser des questions et vous les taupes
où c'est une question pour pour les au
belize avec oui parce que grégory pose
là en fait la grande question dans le
livre page 38 il écrit quelqu'un sur
terre c'est il comment on est censé être
après ça donc vous ça se pose
particulièrement pour vous mais je
voudrais dire que vous demandez au delà
du deuil de chagrin est ce que vous avez
eu envie de comprendre ce que vous avez
envie envie d'être face à face avec un
des tueurs et pouvoir vous adresser
directement lui lui poser des questions
et quelques questions anormaux et j'ai
écrit à françois hollande dit écrit à
monsieur macron en leur demandant de
rencontrer salle abdeslam en prison pour
le regarder dans les yeux et pour qu'ils
voient en fait une maman quoi tout
normal l'emmener là photos de chloé et
lui faire voir en fait ce qu'il avait
fait parce qu'est ce que ce petit plat
c'est ce qu'il a fait à part avoir tué
des tas de gens est ce que il a une
image des victimes
voilà j'avais envie de ça et puis un
avocat m'a dit ça risquait de porter
préjudice au procès donc bon je vais
attendre
là je vais attendre qu'il passe en
procès et j'irai le voir après en prison